why you why you stuttering I'm not
stuttering you are stuttering you don't
have you're contesting every single
thing that I'm saying yeah I'm arent how
is it possible how is it possible that
somebody can criticize Hamas but refus
to condemn the idea of an
Israel just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the the Quran why
because they did not have it on their
mobile devices or their gadgets brothers
and sisters imagine you have a app the
Quran app which not only shows you how
much rewards you get but reminds you to
read the Quran gives you reminders
download the Quran app now and let it
testify for you on that you read it
wherever you
wasalam alikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends all Praises belong to Allah
subhana wa tala for how the Piers Morgan
V Muhammad hijab debate went and after
after praising Allah subhana wa tala we
want to thank our brother Muhammad hijab
and may Allah preserve him and bless him
inshallah me and my wife was watching
that video Subhan Allah wah he was so
happy to see how it turned out he even
made him stutter the question that I
want to ask before I come to Pi Morgan
as well as well inshah is that what made
somebody who's a human being like Pier
Morgan refrain at any cost to condemn
the idea before we come to Pi Morgan and
watch that clip brother and sisters
Muhammad hijab puts any Less hours
sleepless nights We Know M myself Zan we
know cuz we are with Him believe me
anything that pertains to the umah a
Muslim being harmed or a innocent person
whoever is for that matter being wronged
he is somebody that will lose sleep over
something that pertaining to the Deen
pertaining to somebody insult the
prophet sallam or Islam this is the kind
of person he brother sisters W he he W
he sleeps four to 5 hours a night and
and W the books that he reads the
preparation that he does for the debate
I look in admiration literally admiring
and blessing him and making Dua for him
that Allah preserves him to perfect and
to help his Dean which he has which
you've seen very clearly W he is a man
may Allah bless and preserve him and
protect him from evil eye and envy and
jealousy W may Allah bless him inshah
Zan Also may Allah bless him who edits a
lot of M's videos may Allah bless and
preserve him as well they work as a team
we all work as a team that's what I
wanted to say because he deserves that
priest coming to PS Morgan look at this
clip guys in this clip you guys saw for
yourself but look at it again why you
why you stuttering I'm not stuttering
you are stuttering you don't have you're
contesting every single thing that I'm
saying yeah that's I'm saying at the end
1300 people were brutally people been
killed on other side abused 2,000 have
been killed on the other back to the
Ambassador okay but did you condemn that
yes or no I don't think so you refus to
condemn no you do refuse to why are you
putting words in my mouth cuz you're not
you're not condemning it are you what do
you want me to
condemn excellent what do I want you to
condemn I want you to condemn the fact
that the IDF knowing that it's more
probable than not pressing buttons from
the sky killing innocent civilians
10,000 of them children that that is a
war crime and that is not acceptable
morally just like you cond the other one
is it condemnable I believe given the
scale of what Hamas did on October the
7th Israel is entitled to kill children
how is it possible how is it possible
that somebody can criticize Hamas but
refuse to condemn the idea of an Israel
brothers and S it is
impossible that someone like P Morgan to
make himself look humiliated he got
embarrassed absolutely decimated
destroyed intellectually buried but he
still did not condemn the idea for
Israel why because his bosses I'm very
very sure
before he went on that show he was told
categorically clear by his bosses
remember the freedom of speech of the
media the freedom of speech yep you can
insult Islam but no one else for that
matter they told him very clearly no
matter what happens Pier no matter how
much you get humiliated embarrassed
slapped around intellectually no matter
how self the debate goes you are not
allowed to criticize or condemn Israel
or the IDF how could some somebody get
humiliated to that level and refuse at
the same breath condemning Hamas and
then same breath children being
massacred he refused not only that
justified what Israel is doing to his
Palestinians brothers and sisters this
shows you categorically clear they don't
give a damn about freedom of speech and
democracy and we no no no no no no they
don't care these people are hypocrites
monarcs the these people are double
standard Hypocrites and you saw that the
discomfort that he had the stuttering
that he was doing which you saw on
camera when our brother M hijab like a
lion was eating him up intellectually he
couldn't say nothing and he was the if
they said what does the word panus looks
like we would say p Moran but it also
shows me that deep down he was
threatened and he knows he would lose
his job there are people who been
arrested for saying being pro
Palestinian so so he knew very well
peers who talks about freedom of speech
he knew not for them there is no freedom
of speech and Allah says in the and I'll
end on
this for the Believers this is do not
desper do not despair Allah subh tala
Allah says in the
Quran
but on that day the Believers will be
laughing at the disbelievers that's
correct as as they are sat on canopied
couches looking on the Believers will be
asked have the disbelievers not been
paid for what they used to do that is a
promise of Allah do not ever think like
Allah says in the Quran that Allah is
unaware of what the evil do was do he
only delays them for a time where their
eyes are going to look in horror me and
you and every single Muslim is going to
witness this like Allah says sitting on
couches and we are going to ask have the
disbelievers the enemies the Hostile
ones of course being paid back for what
they used to do and indeed they will do
not ever for a moment think that Allah
subhana is going to let them go SC free
never be patient or Believers our
Palestinian brothers and sisters and
those who are suffering who have
suffered all around the world a day will
come that you will look and say oh Allah
you're the best of planets and may this
be a form that you expiates their sins
and they enter Jenna without any
recognition to all those people who have
been oppressed and massacred at their
hands may Allah bless brother hijab may
Allah preserve him and may Allah make
him a means that Islam is defended by
his hands it's an honor to be working
with
him